[Musica]
sì gli dà tutto bene set va tutto
benissimo perché sta grattando devo
andare ad una festa con sacchi con l'api
si pensa votasse quella bambola
o cambino il cimitero va bene io vado a
mangiare ma dopo
[Musica]
bene ora che se n'è andata
posso parlarti legno che era segreta
pieno non segreto per attuarlo milioni
ha detto aiuta certo farò di tutto per
accontentarmi strappi timi pure qual è
questo piano innanzitutto noi abbiamo la
cinica liberarsi di vita così non sarà
delle braccia la specchiera dimmi pure
come volete
[Musica]
no merlino tu non lo puoi mangiare
questa socio colato
[Musica]
murray ma io prima ero come termico
mangiavo sempre tutto quanto una volta
pensa che ho mangiato una torta intera e
poi mi sono sentito male
ecco perché adesso non mangerò solo metà
[Musica]
dai berlino non ricordare i voti non te
lo posso dare questa torta di cioccolato
che ho detto ti senti male come dopo
anzi ti fa su supermario presidente
addirittura morire meglio di no
e tuttavia adesso come faremo certo
strappi ritiene faremo grandi cose
organizzerò un esercito dei burattini al
mahdi ore è lecito pronto adatta anche
ai tordi il sito di burattini perché un
giorno metà con un fatto non mi sono
neanche reso conto come facciamo adesso
di giudice ad anita allora facciamo così
io mi sono mangiato il cioccolato e adam
italy diciamo che tutti siano andata
tutta la parte restante si è d'accordo
così almeno non mi sgrida è un po di
toccante crocchette che penso quindi mi
raccomando eh
diciamola così che sicuramente crederà
ve lo dico io non mi crede
homer lì non mi raccomando eh non le
dire che sono stato io a mangiarne tutta
diciamolo che sei stato tu a mangiarne
metallo e io ho mangiato solo il
cioccolato insieme tanto convinto a fare
fatto ma ti prometto che ti do un osso
nuovo grandissimo solo per ora tagliamo
una fetta della vita e ce la portiamo
così sarà contento
va bene dai italiano piccola però è
perché ce lo siamo quando ha vinto ormai
una fetta per anita piccolina e con
l'acqua e andiamo a portare anita che ho
portato un pezzo di torta che stai
facendo
devo dirti una cosa importante
di cosa vuoi parlarne devi andare via da
qua ok in campo allora no devi andare
via da questa casa ti senti bene c'è
qualcosa che non puoi andare via e bat
che da quando arrivato a questa bambola
si sta comportando davvero in maniera
strana
no non è vero
e invece sì da me la massa ma ti vedi
come ti stai comportando strappi e mio
tipo una torta tunità bambola non mi
interessa
come si sentì lascia stare slap che vai
via aspetti
[Musica]
si è fatto scusa io non volevo farti del
male
[Musica]
mi dispiace
cioè niente
e va bene non mi lasci altra scelta che
ha la sua scelta
[Musica]
bravissimo ha funzionato
bene il pelo compito è andato a buon
fine e cioè ma dai lei incrocio vitale
ora nasce ti spieghi meglio della
missione c'è un'altra cosa
importantissima che dovrai fare perché
adesso punta ecco vedi che io nella mia
forma elaborati no non posso fare tante
cose come pure perdere quindi vedi gli
avrei bisogno di un corpo umano che cosa
ho bisogno porti vento rumor ci sono
tanti metodi temi resta per poter
diventare mano a cui sono più rischiosi
estetico o meno 600 sono meno grandi
cose assieme
il mio potere se molte leghe e potrò
finalmente realizzare il mio più grande
obiettivo
non posso ancora sera te la devi fidarti
di me per di verona ho bisogno solo di
una cosa ho bisogno
bella e dopo potremo finalmente
conquistare il mondo a siena
allora sei pronta la legalizzazione
che cosa devo fare io ho detto bene
ci siamo subito il processo
[Applauso]
[Musica]